the Olympic gold medal winning
bobsledder Curtis tomasevic is back on
the program to talk about this he won
gold in 2010 Curtis how often were you
tested that year oh well it's hard to
say yes but I think in my ten years of
bobsledding I was tested pretty close to
100 times most of those were out of
competition but some of those are you
know right after race 2 in competition
test two all right give me an idea of
where you were drug tested I was saying
you could be a shopping mall naked tap
you on the shoulder yeah well in my ten
years from 2004 to 2014 the rules
changed a little bit over that time and
when i first started basically you to
provide one hour a day that you where
you're going to be your your whereabouts
and they could show up within that hour
any day of the year and once they show
up there they would call you and you had
one hour to report their after that they
actually eliminated that phone call rule
so made it even harder you had to be in
that location for one hour you missed
that one hours and you get a Miss test
three miss tests in the failed test and
so it's pretty strict but there was one
time that the doping control officer
came to my door and I was just in ready
to walk out headed to a funeral actually
and of course I wasn't gonna miss the
funeral and I didn't have to to go at
that moment I yes so I basically said
you can follow me and you know feel like
an idiot in the back to the church and
so they they came and luckily I drank
enough water on the way there that I was
able to provide a sample in the bathroom
at the back of the church just before
the funeral but you know things like
that kind of happen often any other
strange places that you've been asked to
give a urine sample uh my one hour was
running up pretty close one time and so
the doping control officer agreed to
meet me halfway between where I was and
where he was and so we met at a gas
station on the side of a highway yeah I
know dorm room bathrooms yeah just you
know training facilities you know going
into somebody's office rather than the
bathroom just because a little more
private but they're in there watching
you from start to finish
yeah I mean by definition by rule they
have to see the screen so they
technically ask you to drop your pants
to your knees and shirt off sometimes
and they just sit there and watch you
your shirt off that's technically the
rule needs to be sure it all the way up
or off but as long as they see the
stream usually hit the cup and you can
provide I think it's 85 or 90
milliliters then that's that's what
they're looking for how humbling is that
you know at first it's a yeah you're
exactly you get a little stage fright
sometimes but after a while I mean I
could provide 90 samples at the drop of
a hat now I think that you played
football at Nebraska so what what's
what's uh under the tougher drug testing
policy college football or being an
Olympian definitely Olympian yeah in
college we got tested by our team by the
big 12 at that time and then also by NC
double-a they each come once a year or
so but yeah after that once I got to
into the international testing pool with
you sada in with water then yeah they
were testing me quite often quite a bit
and it makes it hard to really feel
sorry for the you know the professional
athletes Major League Baseball and those
guys when they're complaining about so
now you're retired so do you miss having
somebody call you up to say I'm coming
over Curtis yeah do i do I invite my
friends over Jesus hey we we appreciate
you watching and thanks for the stories
Curtis yeah good to catch up with you
again that's a Curtis tomasevic she won
a gold medal in bobsled in 2010 the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you